at least 100 people have died many more
have been injured after fire broke out
at a wedding in Northern Iraq officials
say up to a thousand people had been
attending the ceremony near the city of
mosul when the blaze happened it is
being reported that fireworks may have
started the
place a whole family has passed away I
found the four of them dead had I gone
to the wedding with them I too would
have died each member of my family is
gone now my family my children and my
brother they only take money the hall
does not have any fire extinguishers and
the owner also brought barley grass used
as sealing materials unfortunately
unfortunately we Christians witnessed
this because of
him Mahmud abdulwahed has more from
Baghdad rescue and fire extinguishing
operations we're going simultaneously to
deal with the fire accident
that broke out in a wedding hall in
aladia District part of NOOA province in
Northern Iraq now uh local sources that
in the area say that what also helped
causing that number of deaths and
injuries is uh Burns and Suffocation
also uh there is no proper uh safety
measures in h place and also there like
for example there is no proper emergency
exits in the building what also helped
exacerbating the uh disaster is that
flamable materials used in the
construction of the hole that helped
igniting the fire and causing that huge
number of deaths and injuries now uh
medical facilities in the uh District
are short of medical equipment and some
cases have been uh transferred to
neighbor provinces to uh receive medical
treatment an investigation has been uh
uh ordered and forensic teams have been
ordered to collect evidence in order to
also identify uh uh causes of that
helped exacerbating the disaster